ask them what they think of stephen
greer ce5 protocol
well um i think it's worth a try you
know i i had a chance to interview some
guys who uh
they they are sort of like the prophet
yahweh it's this guy who 20 years ago
said he could call in ufos and he'd go
out and meditate and try to draw things
in and uh and sometimes it worked and
sometimes it didn't uh there's a a group
of fellows that i know who have tried
this picked up the mantle and have been
had some amazing experiences that
they've videotaped
um
summoners i think they call it summoning
so it it does happen it it can happen
stephen greer who did some really great
early work in getting ufo whistleblowers
to come forward getting their testimony
out to
national
media organizations is a champion of
this ce5 he charges a lot of money for
people that go out into the desert when
them and call in flying saucers uh a lot
of people are put off by how
expensive it gets and and where the
money goes especially since it looks
like people can do this on their own
without paying steven greer to do it i
you know i don't know if it really works
but what the heck i say it's worth
giving it a try
column do you have any thoughts on it
yeah i would agree i think uh i think
it's worth
you know attempting it um i know that
it's been attempted in multiple places
there's been large programs in south
america
um associated with uh summoning uh ufos
and uh from the reports that i've seen
mostly um not scientific reports but
books and uh and magazine articles that
there does seem to be a level of success
but i would inject a note of caution
into this is be careful what you
actually
uh summon and you know um it it
it could be that these
uh objects come in all shapes and sizes
and like we've said for the last uh
hours so we don't know what the agenda
of of these objects are i mean it could
be some some have a benign agenda and it
could be that some have uh not a benign
agenda so i would inject a note of
caution i personally
uh would not do that
because i have too much much respect
uh and caution regarding this phenomena
because we know too little about this
phenomenon and uh it's a case of be
careful what you wish
yeah i feel exactly the same i've been
told kurt look into it and perform it
i'm not i'm not going to at least not
anytime soon because
it's playing with fire it's worse than
playing with fire when i was speaking to
tom delong he expressed similar
sentiments saying that you don't know
what you're dealing with and it's
it could be extremely extremely
dangerous so i'm of that same opinion
yeah i mean i i
i kind of liken it to i mean if you
summon anything without uh
without careful sort of training and all
of that
um you you really are opening yourselves
up i would say the same goes for
ayahuasca tourism for example and this
this whole idea of sort of going to
somebody's place that you don't know who
they are and taking a bunch of ayahuasca
or dmt or any of the hallucinogenics um
again it's be careful what you wish for
uh i mean the originator of this whole
dmt phenomenon rick strassmann um who
was actually you know he was fundamental
in sort of initiating the the focus on
dmt in the western world and he did a an
nih-sponsored study of injecting a whole
bunch of volunteers
under under medical medical supervision
uh in new mexico and uh there's an
enormous number of these uh young
volunteers
uh reported
encountering these creatures and unusual
uh you know unusual people in in these
other realms
but you know rick strassmann later on
decided to back away from that research
because he found that some of these
uh these young people were having
long-term psychological effects and
again you know
under under control conditions it's all
very well to do this but you know what
are the long-term effects and what are
what are these entities that people are
actually needing and conversing with i
mean do you really get the secrets of
the universe or do you get something
that you may not have bargained for and
that you find very a lot of difficulty
in getting rid of and you know i mean
the list goes on and on teenagers
playing ouija boards and what have we
you've got to have a certain amount of
caution uh when you're approaching these
kinds of phenomena and um especially
when we know so little about what the
long-term effects are